hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space ok we just dumb
fix the gravity doodad not really sure
what's up hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
let go oh oh hey back off buddy
ok Oh big boy ha ha get higher
get it Oh hahaha pwned you hardcore
oh man Oh what was that thing okay
that's what happened to that guy okay
and that's why that big hole is there
hey ha ha back off buddy oh I got my eye
on you
Oh glad I didn't sell my plasma cutter
anyway I was something see ya okay get
back into it
Oh didn't scare me at all I was way too
tough for you all right going back ah I
better cut it
Oh back off buddy
hi all right
hi oh come on
yeah that's right eat it eat it buddy
clone gone with your head I know that
wasn't ready whatever I don't need ammo
so tough I can mail ate them all oh look
at me so okay
trust elevators I never trust over hi
can you hear me oh you're alive Kendra
no they attacked me I ran for it and
having just he just disappeared oh wow
nice to see you're alive and well Hamid
i barricaded myself in the computer core
that's us I can hear the moving outside
but I don't think they know I'm in here
I could log into everything from here I
hacked the route and found some reports
from the colony even before they crack
the pond at the colonists were
experiencing a widespread dementia make
sense it seems to be related to some
artifact they found on the planet
something called the marker I'll keep
looking I've got your location and I'm
going to unlock the door to fuel storage
you can get to the engine chamber from
there
sounds good to me because I know why
that's important Wow okay um get rid of
that
oh that's money in the bank six-pack
I'll hold on to you umm River blades
I'll keep on those I don't have much
inventory space so uh let's see here
ah you know what I'm getting rid of the
pulse now I'm not getting rid of that's
right well I'm not I'm not
I'm keeping it I don't care what you all
say it's a good weapon maybe I don't
know probably not oh man okay alright
I'm not gonna buy anything again till I
know what to buy if there's probably
more like upgrades for the suit that can
be gotten gotten ah ha ha yes I want to
overwrite it for size okay where the
heck II had like
that way okay uh-huh big door through
variable gravity zone I love my variable
gravity and no oxygen oh oh what's that
a dead guy
what's that floating item air I don't
need air gosh golly goodness
entering studio gravity any hidden item
out there probably oh there's a box
right in front me boom gimme gimme
okay what do I do umm so you need to get
down there there we go all right um
where am I going
I have no idea um Wow I can't even tell
what is it out where that's where I came
from right I need to get oh my goodness
my head Oh over there no up there yeah
alright oh holy hell thirty seconds of
air ah get over get over get over get
over you know get get get get oh oh like
it ain't no thang
come on with a damn door
who's there down there okay I did
not loud enough for you guys I don't
know if you can hear it
it's at goopy stuff
oh it's everywhere Oh Oh what are you oh
oh oh that is wrong oh that is wrong
look at him look at the bed awesome
sorry guy put you out of your misery I'm
here I guess you're dead enough
um well whoa hey
all right I'm just put sorry all right
I'm not gonna waste ammo okay I don't
trust that vent I'm just gonna say that
right now
that guy's screaming an egg this is
temple screw the adjustable I can't
restore it by myself with all the other
[ __ ] going on it's obvious this is
sabotage I'm heading for the bridge and
then I need to find Elizabeth I gotta
get her off this ship it's not safe no
kidding it's not safe this look at this
this is ridiculous
how do you let things get this way aah
aah I can't run on it either
Oh our monsters just gonna like jump out
of it probably boom oh not on I do not
like that vent our node
I'm ready for something to jump out I'm
just ready okay
engineer log organic growth unidentified
growth see me in other parts of the ship
has now reached engineer no kidding do
something about it oh it's spreading
faster than we can cut up starting the
engine spoke you'll hit the main chamber
by the day after tomorrow yeah your
Doc's kind of failed you on them come on
open it up
come on a schedule here come on yeah oh
good it be goobie
oh is that like a sensitive part should
I cut that can I can I cut that I don't
know it looks different
I'll come back up if I need you not
gonna waste any more Hey all right I got
a saw I got Biggles so huh oh I do not
trust that Ben
I got my on you've been high what god I
was a dead guy
I don't like this place
I don't like it at all all right what
was that ah and the reason I got the gun
ah get off me get off me get off me
shoot damn it
oh come on F F sorry I don't trust you
didn't trust boom
hi
huh I heard some yards um
Oh like this
I like this
come on go geez how much time do I have
to press a key button
okay I'm guessing that Dorking he died
like any of you why don't they have a
stasis pack handle recharge right there
ah come on
if I stomp the crap out of them
um powerlock oh cool good thing I bring
don't trust you all right
rip your blades off darn it
oh man things get clogged up so quickly
I'm not ever okay
ah don't oh come on my inventory is full
garnet is there anything else I can give
I need that schematic line racks I don't
need line racks right now I will
probably need them when I get
other thing but not right not line right
don't pick up the liner good on
everything maybe okay
now we're good seaming oh damn it I
couldn't let you get killed
Oh aspirin experts just gone up so good
up so skill how was that oh oh it took
like ten shots wasted my stasis hole
alright job I got a thing oh hey wait
what oh what's that you want some fire
there we go
oh and it blew up another guy ha ha ha
ha sucks for you gave me another one
no I don't want wait
oh I just learned something I can use
there oh can I like rip them off their
body mm-hmm me likey right there there
yeah wow sounds good to me
okay all right I gotta cut it here thank
you guys so much for watching and I will
see you in the next part bye bye